vamos a pensar un poco que obtenemos de
la multiplicación y de la suma de dos
números racionales
si yo empiezo con el producto con la
multiplicación de dos números racionales
y supongamos que tengo uno que se llama
a am entre b tengo el número a entre b
ya esté aunque sabe a entre b ya esté lo
voy a multiplicar por otro número que
sea racional se me ocurre m entre n
bueno cuando multiplico estos dos que
voy a obtener esto es exactamente lo
mismo que a por m que apele me recuerda
que se multiplican
así los las fracciones a paul m ok ya
esto dividido entre b x en déjame
cambiar el color b por n
ahora date cuenta que si a / b es un
número racional y m entre n es un 1 y
racional a es un número entero y m es un
número entero por lo tanto cuando
multiplique dos números enteros voy a
obtener también un número entero y de
igual manera va a pasar con los
denominadores b es un número entero en
es un número entero y por lo tanto b por
n es un número entero como tengo la
razón o la proporción estoy comparando
los números enteros entonces puedo decir
que este número de aquí también es
racional este también es más
ok de lujo si me tomo la multiplicación
de dos números racionales obtén un
número racional
ahora vamos a cambiar de color y vamos a
pensar en números racionales cuando se
suman supongamos que tengo a entre b ok
ya esto le voy a sumar le voy a sumar
otro número racional y para seguir con
esta misma lógica voy a tomarme m / n ok
que obtengo de la suma de estos dos
racional es bueno para tomarme la suma
de estos racionales pues hay varias
formas de hacerlo lo primero que se me
ocurre es que podríamos tomar un
denominador común y el denominador común
va a ser b por n voy a tomar como
denominador común ave por n
vamos a poner esta línea kim b por n b
por n ok y bueno para saber que me va a
quedar aquí arriba lo que esto se les
convertirá esta fracción en algo que
tenga un denominador común debe prender
y para eso voy a multiplicar tanto
arriba como abajo por n tanto arriba
como abajo por n
ok de tal manera que ya tengo el
denominador común que yo quería y ahora
sí voy a tener bn / p n s n
antes cabe ponerlo así a por n ok ya
esto le voy a sumar le voy a sumar y
ahora me voy a fijar en esta fracción si
me fijo en esta fracción de aquí lo que
me falta para tener este denominador
común bm es multiplicar tanto arriba
como abajo por ver entonces
multiplicamos por ver y por ver de tal
manera que abajo tengo ya n b
vn y arriba me queda por ver y lo voy a
poner cuando este color m por b por b de
tal manera que quiero que te des cuenta
de algo muy importante con esta
expresión que tengo aquí en la parte de
abajo
tengo el producto de dos números enteros
y en la parte de arriba tengo un número
entero la multiplicación de los enteros
es un entero más otro entero y un entero
más otro entero también es un número
entero por lo tanto este de aquí es de
aquí es lo mismo que un entero entre
otro entero
es lo mismo que una razón de dos números
enteros o una proporción de dos números
enteros o estamos comparando dos números
enteros lo cual me dice que es un número
racional racional y está de lujo ya me
estoy dando cuenta que si tengo la
multiplicación o el producto de dos
números racionales obtengo racional y
por otra parte si me tomo la suma de dos
números racionales también obtengo un
racional